yo I always wondered so there was like
this era um I'm really close with
Dilated Peoples and raqqa and Hyper
science and Baboo and obviously shots
are they the best hell yeah I love those
guys
um
they really opened my world uh my taste
in another a whole another way
um to like digging into like different
[__] that I was into at the time but I
remember as a kid there was the random
because you were close like you were
cool with Paul obviously right you're
cool with M but then there's like this
weird beef between like Dilated Peoples
Everlasting Eminem did you ever try to
like bring those guys together nah it
was weird man I think I think Everlast
from what I remember correctly you know
don't quote me here but I think ever
last seen M on the elevator and M just
didn't say nothing to him but M's like
he didn't look the same right and didn't
realize it he didn't realize who he was
maybe right right and and was a [__]
Everlast fan you know from what I hear
so ever that's just you know I don't
know what happened then he wrote some
[__] about him yeah and then I remember
there was like the dilated [__] and then
evidence had a song called uh Searching
for Bobby Fisher so I was just wondering
because you were kind of like it felt
like I'm like Switzerland you might have
you know I don't know if you try to put
a call in none now I just figured all
that y'all [__] up yeah you're [__]
with them we got good luck with that
[__] man good luck I mean like even why
but um I don't even think I heard the
dilated song ever yeah there was an
Evidence song called Searching for Bobby
Fischer that was I think I heard that
one no but I had um a Napster hit yeah
so yeah I brought Paul I remember when I
met Paul I flew him out to LA to meet
with me and I had a barbecue um to
manage Cyprus and he came out here and
that's how I met Paul because Theo Theo
was my lawyer and I was like yo I need a
new manager bro
what year was this
before um before um rock superstar album
so it was like 2099 yeah 99 and I was
he's like yo I got this this lawyer he's
got an ear like me and he's managing
this artist Eminem and didn't blow up
here yeah
flew his ass out had to barbecue and
locked in with Paul what what was was it
label like why did you guys do a rap
Superstar and a rock superstar
difference because um check this out so
we was up at Columbia and you know now
we're going into the fifth album
so we'd go to the urban Department that
was after the album after Dr
greenthumber before after after that's
right okay it was like yeah that was
four that was the fifth album yeah so we
would go up to the label and was like
all right let's go this marketing plan I
go to the urban Department it was like
no no you guys are
you guys are alternative I know we ain't
so we go up to the other we go up to the
next floor and they was like oh no you
guys are the urban Department
and they don't work together and
everybody's passing the buck nobody
wanted to do their [__] job and I was
like you my [__] pieces of [__] check
this out I'm gonna give you all a rock
song and a rap song So now what's your
[__] excuse me you got one you got
one so I did we had a song called can't
get the best of me and rap Superstar
and then I walked into the meeting with
Donnie Aina and he was like no this is
the single we're not doing rock song
with this is the single I'm putting all
the money behind this one I was like oh
[__] this ain't gonna work so I went in
the studio a couple days later and did
the remix Superstar wow okay yeah
because I was because coming from the
radio side um you know I've done radio
my whole life and
like you said there's some times where
there'll be a record
like uh there was a shout to my I have a
friend uh yellow wolf who had a song and
he put a song out um through Shady
called let's roll but Kid Rock was on
the hook
so he ran into that issue where he was
like a hip-hop artist but they're like
we don't know what to do with this
because you know it's like hip-hop
inspired but it's like we grew bigger
than hip-hop we just became our own
thing you know for sure we got so big
and and you know just harnessing that
rock and roll energy like I said Public
Enemy LL Run DMC Beastie Boys you know
what I mean and just coming from that
DNA from that side and um
so that's why I was like all right
here's something from both of y'all but
both of y'all can work and nobody can
complain and point fingers because the
record before they dropped the ball
because nobody was working it because
there was nobody wanted to do their
[__] job and pointing fingers so I
was like maybe this is the way the way
around and plus at that time you know I
was seeing all these whack [__]
that couldn't really rhyme but they was
rapping on Rock [__] where they sounded
decent you know and they was having
these big careers what year was that
that was very much the little era of
that happening so then I was you know
the other layer that actually was me
like oh yeah well yeah I could do this
[__] too yeah let me do some rock [__]
and then let me bang on y'all
[__] with this [__] and then at
the same time I produced um
some [__] for Pearl Jam and Sonic Youth
crazy I mean in some different rock
bands just to like let me see what I can
do and just I didn't know you did
September program that's amazing shout
out to project